black is going to go bishop e4
king h2 but maybe this is not true
no i think here black would of course
give a check and king g2 knight f4
so
ah we have bishop f1 is it mate already
no after bishop e4 bishop g2 rook h3
trackmate of course this is not the move
but after bishop e4 white resigned if i
see it correctly
after king h2 simply bishop d5 would
attack the rook and
the knight and what a game what a game
congratulations for the leader
it was an amazing performance by
neptu
well done
we have to know that that ali reza
was playing the opening quite strange
because already at the early stage of
the game he was playing something which
was not expected
in this position king h1 rook c8 though
i believe that he had already he was
behind in development but his next
movement he played g4 and after h6 he
played h4
it was something
i felt that it goes wrong you can't
afford to yourself to play h4 g4 trust
me i'm a big g4 h4 believer but in this
position there is no
foundation for something like this